this is a monster of a question there a
putz together one of the ways that
you've emerged looking at it is if you
have a look at the second page there's
Part B Part 2 part 1 and part 2 y man
how many how far could they nest this
thing so this is a very very long
question many many pieces that all come
together and all heading towards Part B
Part 5 so they will what to this let's
have a look at Part A and understand how
they get this triggering on which we're
going to use later on I've begun the
proof so you can see I start with the
left-hand side it's easy to go from the
expansion this is just stating this is
just quoting what the result is where do
I go from here in order to get to the
result they want I really like one of
two lines off okay all right so I'm
interested because if you have a look at
the fall that they've given it to you
you can't do that but it seems to me
like it might be easy just to take a
factor out like you're multiplied by a
Soviet dividing mightily but being that
the next the realm I to prove has a cos
a cos B out the front yeah
I'm just going to take that out right
now and say well that's one plus okay
now if I've got this inside then both of
these things have been divided by cos a
cos B right and if I divide that well
that's that's the result isn't it
now B that it's a result to prove and
they've given me the result that's close
I'm gonna go ahead and actually write
that light even though it's somewhat
trivial to get to the result I need so
I've got this okay so that was part a
part one part two this is okay given
some particular values on a and B those
angles by the way just look at the inner
qualities for a second just look at them
briefly what does this mean could you
give me some words for a and B okay B's
are cute that's the first thing I can
say okay so being that yeah you have a
look at this next part right if they're
suggesting you see that but down the
bottom a minus B equals PI onto
that means the difference between a and
B is PI or 2 so for example let's go to
degrees because they'll be easier to
think of a numbers if B were 10 then a
would be 100 if B were 20 then a be 110
whatever you go 90 degrees forward right
so just from the inequalities you don't
know that much about a but when you see
that next piece that they give you that
final result a minus B equals pi/2 that
tells you okay basic Ute a zip juice so
just so you can see that and not get you
know clouded by all of the notation
that's what it actually means
okay so if I know that those things are
the case in the qualities if 10 a 10 B
is equal to negative 1 then what happens
to this first line this thing this whole
thing here because a minus B this whole
running inside collapses to 0 does that
make sense like you're solving something
that's been factorized right so if this
case then this there are many ways to 0
ok now we know for cause whatever equals
0 there's an infinite number of
solutions given your values of a B but a
and B of just being restricted right so
therefore I can say there's only one
solution to this in the domain that's
been provided to us right in other words
a minus B is going to only be 2 and I'm
going to say that because a is cute
sorry a some shoes and B's
so that restriction gives me this factor
okay so file that away and they get
ready to UM use it in this next part so
have a look it's a basketball player now
you remember I said to you this is a
projectile motion question there's a
projectile the basketball but it's not a
very projectile motion kind of question
because they give you all of the pieces
that are required in projectile motion
they've given you the equation for
horizontal displacement and the equation
for vertical displacement for the
mattress down because we're gonna need
them shortly pop baby pop one so I get
given my V T cos theta and I've got my V
T sine theta takeaway so normally for
projectile motion question where do I
begin ordinarily very good so by
definition horizontally there's no
acceleration after the initial
projection and then vertically
you've got gravity now have a look at my
vertical displacement equation
where's gravity in this equation where
is it it's the minus Phi T squared right
because it would have started from minus
10 would have integrated up to minus 10
T and then integrate one more step up to
minus 5 T squared so you recognize it if
you see that minus 5 or the minus 4.9
that's kind of a giveaway right
depending on what gravitational course
that they chose all right so you're not
required to prove these equations that's
nice so when you turn over you have a
look at this result that's required to
be proven required to prove and you look
at it and you say why could this what on
earth is this
that's a subtraction okay
and it's three marks this is a little
bit like the style of the question I
showed you a day or two ago yeah two ago
we're on this first part it's like whoa
where do I even like this part it's it's
it's hard to access this right it
doesn't look like something you've
obviously seen before which is why
they've given you these right they're
trying to say look we know you can get
this it's kind of routine to get this
you just it's a great good four times 95
now I want to see if you can use this
okay now having been given these
equations there's one other piece of
information in the question that they
tell us that will help us get to here
look at how part one starts what do I
know about this part of it laughter this
okay I have a set of coordinates that it
goes to right so D comma H they're
significant because they're the
coordinates of the hoop I think it is
right so the player lands the shot
presumably now what this does is that
this connects these two equations
together right it means for some value
of T for some particular time that you
can think of which I don't know and I
don't need to know because if you have a
look at the rest of the question it's
nothing to do with time okay for some
particular time the x value will take
this adds simultaneously the Y value
will take that okay so therefore I've
got to put all this to get up couldn't
combine all of them into one piece to
try and get this relationship okay so
where I'm going to begin is I'm going to
say well what time is that what time is
that but to find out what that is but so
that I can put that into the other
equations right so I'm gonna say at time
I'm gonna designate it I'm gonna give it
a name just so I can talk about it I'm
just gonna say well it's the final time
it's like you've landed the hoop right
so you can call it anything you like I'm
going to pull it time I make it cuz I
think it's the Lost know what the great
guy that we're caught said but we'll use
it for other please so at this final
time right it's just a concert by
choosing I know what the x-coordinate is
right
beacuse okay so therefore I'm just going
to bring that into this horizontal
displacement equation I'm going to say
therefore D equals V times time Omega
cos feel okay whatever time I made it
happens to be so it's going to rearrange
that so I know what the time is
looks like I just have to divide the
root and now I have in terms of the
distance iron from the hoop in terms of
how fast I threw it how hard I throw
that wall and what eggless I project it
at I know when the balls going to lay it
in the hoop okay